two.
Wow. Wow.
I didn't forget this forget.
>> Amen. Amen.
It's so weird.
>> You looked exactly
>> think I would think I would like to
think I'm funny.
No, she's older than me. She's
47.
No, 46.
Just
Welcome everyone to the table. We're so
glad you're here. My name is Janine. My
pronouns are she and her. And we welcome
all of you here and all of you online.
And I want you to know that you're not
only welcome here, but you are
celebrated here.
Okay, we have a few announcements for
you guys. We will have a child
dedication during services on Sunday,
March the 8th. We want to intentionally
partner with parents and families
as they seek to disciple their children
in the way of Jesus and also to raise
them in the midst of a loving community.
And if you're interested in that, the QR
code, the famous QR code is available to
you.
Okay. On March the 15th, we're going to
have one of our special services. It'll
be at 5:00. It's called Sunday Unbound
and it will be in the Family Life Center
right behind this building. Check.
>> We are focusing on what it means to be a
community. And if you can and you want
to contribute to the potluck, please
scan that emphasis QR code. That is
March the 15th.
>> All right. I know how it can be kind of
nerve-wracking sometimes to come into a
church service. So, I want you to know
that we
people here
>> who have any kind of anxiety or anything
like that. We have an accessibility
bucket on the table over here to the
right. It has noiseancelling headphones
in it. All kinds of fidgets, coloring
sheets. We ask that you take what you
need during the service and put it back
in the bucket when we're done.
All right, everyone. I want to bring
your attention to the candles that are
lit at the front. These candles are a
sign of the presence of Christ with us.
>> Fully human
>> and fully divine.
All right. If you'll take a deep breath
with me and settle in,
we will now exit the kingdom of noise
and hurry and productivity.
And we will enter a kingdom
>> of silence and stillness
and simplicity.
Sacred space.
A place for prayer,
worship and adoration.
A place to be Christ. Revelation of God.
Heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace
define you
to embrace you
to bend your heart.
Thanks Jonah. Thanks Johnny. If you guys
would stand with us we're going to get
started with worship in just a second. I
wanted to read really quickly out of
Ephesians chapter 3. Um these verses
were just on my heart for our community
this week as I was preparing and I
wanted to share them especially in the
spirit of family and um us having this
gift of gathering together as part of
the body of Christ. And I feel like
sometimes we can kind of feel like this
separate siloed off um unit. Um but the
truth is that we are not. We are part of
the larger work that um that God had our
heart. We are part of his family. We are
not alone. We're not on our own. We do
not have to be isolated.
And Ephesians says, "For this reason, I
kneel before the father and with and
from whom his whole family in heaven and
on earth deres its name." I pray I pray
that out of his glorious riches, he may
strengthen you with power through his
spirit in your inner so that so that
Christ may dwell in your hearts through
faith. And I pray that you being rooted
and established in love may have power
together with all the saints to grasp
how wide and high and high and deep
and to know to know this arises that
surpasses knowledge. that you may be
filled to the measure of the fullness of
God. God
I love you, Lord.
You have me.
You have my soul from my
from
the land. In the land of my soul. So
from life from start
in the in the
Hold on. Our mics aren't working right
now.
All right. Chorus.
So stay here and then let's go to the
chorus. One.
>> Sorry guys. Bear with us.
>> For you have delivered me.
I love you, Lord.
You have my soul from my feet from
stones. I will walk in the land of the
living. My soul from my feet from
stumbles. I will walk in the land of the
living.
I will bless you. I will bless you.
Heat. Heat.
You
know you
have me.
I love you Lord.
You have my soul
from my
star. I will
land my soul. My soul from my
the land of the living.
>> All right. All right, I'm going to
dismiss our kids to go to their classes
with their teachers and they will be
right over there by the double doors.
Thank you, Katie and Abby and Kayie.
Back there tonight. Really appreciate
all the kids ministry team that love all
these guys so well since Sunday after
Sunday after Sunday as they exit. As
they exit, we're going to transition us
into what we call prayers of the people.
If this is your if this is your first
time here, this is a tradition that
we're joining in with and that's part of
Christian history through the years um
where we are just acknowledging what we
carry into this space each week and
we're holding it up together before God
believing that he meets us here with it
and we want to help carry each other's
burdens as well. If you want to follow
along on the screen for now
to read
the parts that are in red out loud
together. Jesus for Jesus for this city
of Sax, Texas and for every city and
community and all who live in them. We
pray to you for the good for the good
earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it. We pray to
you for the for the old and the sick and
for the widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering. We pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them.
We pray to you for the vulnerable, the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender and sexuality, race or
other perceived differences. We pray to
you for those for those experiencing
loss, loneliness, connection,
disconnection, and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health. We
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names for the names of sermons
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts. We pray
to you that they may have life and light
and healing and hope. Peace. peace and
the deep sense of your presence, your
peace. Amen. Amen.
You call me strong and courageous
when when I don't feel like I am.
You could have turned me away, but you
chose me instead.
You say that I'm never naked
when I don't feel like I can.
You see the battle I'm facing and you're
stepping in
it with me.
Working through me
against me
with me.
Through me
against me.
I have a new revelation.
Savior who calls me his friend.
I used to fight.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Yeah. God
me
against me.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Oh my
god.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
What do you
think?
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Holy
heart of Jesus. Jesus our living
from heart of Jesus. Jesus
heart of Christ.
Sing that with us.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
and
heartus.
One last sing one last time.
Jesus, we love you.
Jesus,
we want you.
>> God, would you come? God, would you come
tonight? Your goodness would meet us in
this room, this space where so where so
often we walk in feeling beat up and
torn down.
Tired tired or stressed stressed
confused. Confused and questioning.
Hurt. Hurt hurt. Hurt. Defeated.
Defeated. Defeated. Alone. Alone. Alone.
But God, but God, as we show up to this
space together, we open ourselves open
ourselves up to your healing,
restorative workative work.
We open our We open ourselves up to
forgiveness. Second chances second
chances.
Justice justice. Kindness.
A yoga that is easy and light and light
and light.
God, God, we bring all of ourselves, all
of our stories, all of our baggage and
our pain. our pain.
God, we don't hide it. God, we don't
hide it away or try to pretend it's not
there. We don't want to just put on a
smile. But God, we want to show But God,
we want to show up in our fullness,
knowing that you fully love and accept
each one of us. That you are that you
are fully present and accessible to us.
That we're not alone. That we're not
alone.
That we're not cast. that we're not cast
off or forgotten or pushed aside or
pushed aside. But we are yours. But we
are yours. We are chosen. We are chosen.
We are chosen. Chosen. We are known. We
are known and loved.
Thank you for Thank you for this space
where we can we can claim those things
where we can where we can lean on one
another. where we can where we can
remind each other of who we are. We are
who you who you created us to be from
the very beginning. From the very
beginning,
thank you for that. Thank you for that
kind of love. That kind of that kind of
presence presence. God, we need it. God,
we need it. And we depend on it. It
depend on it.
Thank you. Thank you for meeting us. For
meeting us here tonight. It's in your
name we pray.
Amen. Amen.
Would you guys would you guys turn to
each other and say the peace of Christ
be with you? And then Jesse will get us
started on our message tonight.
Well,
hi.
>> Is that awkward? I'm trying. I I go
through this this moment right here
about 20 times in my head before I walk.
I'm like, "Okay, how do I say hello? How
do I How do I What do I And usually it
comes out. Hey,
just It's weird and it's awkward, but
here we are. Yeah. Um I'm Jesse. I am
not uh the main dude here. Brett is um
as as much as my presence may make you
think that I'm important, I am not. Um
Brett uh is getting some much needed
time off and so uh I get to be here in
his place. And so for those of you who
are new or don't know me, I am usually
on worship team hiding behind a guitar
because when I don't have a guitar,
things get weird and you're about to
witness that. Um, but no, if you're new,
we're so glad you're here. If you're
returning, that's awesome. If you're
online, you are awesome as well. Uh,
most of my family, that's them. They're
they're the ones online. Um, so yeah, I
mean I mean this sincerely that I really
am truly honored to get to be in this
space with you and be a part of a
community of people who desire to have a
community like this with this DNA. Like
it's really really meaningful to me. Um,
and I am just I'm just really grateful.
Um, and I'm really grateful because it's
the first week of Lent. Who's excited?
Lent.
Yeah, Lent.
Okay. Yeah, I think I think I think
that's it. Um, yeah. So, Lent is a
special time every year that we give up
something we enjoy to prove that we're
holy and a part of the club. And so,
that's why I'm up here that I get to
share and we get to all share what we're
going to give up. And um, no, that's not
what we're going to do. Uh, but so, so I
I joke because Lent along with many
other seasons of the church carries with
it a kind of baggage for me. Um, and I
mainly because I grew up in the
evangelicalism of 90s and early 2000s,
uh, which was a weird time of the
church, uh, that produced some weird
people like myself. Um, and I know I I'm
likely not alone, but just anytime Lent
comes up, I am just flooded with
memories of all the weird things I've
fasted from, the weird like fasting
events at the different churches I've
been a part of, the things that I tried
to fast from and then failed and then
felt immense guilt and then lied that I
didn't actually fail. And then I was
feeling guilty about lying about failing
and like like this is what happens. this
is what happens. And so for me there
there is this like there's a lot of
leftover residue from things like Lent
and and similar seasons. And so um I had
to when I when I sat down to write this,
I had to remind myself to not throw out
any beauty and truth that a season like
this can bring. Um and and I think a lot
of us have experienced things like that
in the church where we have to we have
to remember there are good things um in
these seasons, right? So so Lent for
anyone who is not familiar, Lent is the
40 days leading up to Easter. Uh and it
mirrors the 40 days that Jesus was in
the wilderness uh being tempted and
after his baptism. And so the practice
began uh around the 4th century as as a
way for the Christians to prepare and
lead up to the most holy days in the
church calendar. And it begins with Ash
Wednesday. Did anyone go to the Ash
Wednesday service?
Well, you missed out. And here's here's
what here's why. Because you literally
get to rub a cross of ashes on your
forehead. And there is nothing more
metal than that. um to remind you that
you like it's cool because it just
reminds us that we are dust and to dust
we return. You know, all of the fun
religious language that goes with that.
Um but we can't talk about Lent without
revisiting that wilderness desert story
with Jesus and the devil. And I don't
know about you, if this makes you
nervous, good. Um, so, so in the Gospel
account according to Matthew, the story
is told just after Jesus is baptized by
John, which is a really glorious part of
the story. It's really cool. There's a
big voice from heaven that says, "This
is my son, the beloved, in whom I'm well
pleased." And then right after that, it
says that the spirit immediately leads
Jesus out into the wilderness um to be
tempted and tested by the devil, which
sweet. Um, so we're going to read that
passage. It's a little long. Hang with
me. Uh we're It starts in chapter 4
verse 1.
Then Jesus was led by the spirit into
the wilderness to be tempted by the
devil. After fasting 40 days and 40
nights, he was hungry. The tempter came
to him and said, "If you are the son of
God, tell these stones to become bread."
Jesus answered, "It is written, man
shall not live on bread alone, but on
every word that comes from the mouth of
God." Then the devil took him to the
holy city and had him stand on the
highest point of the temple. If you are
the son of God, he said,"Throw yourself
down, for it is written, he will command
his angels concerning you, and they will
lift you up in their hands so that you
will not strike your foot against a
stone." Jesus answered him, "It is also
written," not put the Lord your God to
the test. Again the devil took him to a
very high mountain and showed him all
the kingdoms of the world and their
splendor. All this I will give you, he
said, if you bow down and worship me.
Jesus said to him, "Away from me, Satan,
for it is written, worship the Lord your
God and serve him only." Then the devil
left him and the angels came and
attended to him. I will be uh I am
willing to bet most of you have heard
this story in some form or fashion. Like
there have been entire books written on
just that little I mean there's movies,
there's TV shows, there's movies that
have come out in just in the last year
about this because it's a very popular
uh famous scene in the gospels. Um, and
growing up I thought Jesus was so punk
rock in this. Like I the devil's like,
"Hey, if you're hungry, why don't you
make some bread?" And then Jesus gives
like a kind of scriptural middle finger
to him. Um, it's so it's it's so cool. I
almost cursed again. I'm sorry. Um, but
but I also think like it's it's many of
us cannot really grasp
what this was like for Jesus because not
many of us have fasted like a water fast
for 40 days. Has anyone done a 40-day
water fast? I couldn't wait to ask this.
No. Nice. Okay. I'm I was gonna feel
really dumb if somebody like I have. Um
no m like I I have not done that. I
don't know anyone who has done that,
which makes it really hard for us to
kind of get into the story. Um and so
there's a part of me that that because I
haven't done that, I can kind of get it
mixed up and romanticize what fasting
and being in the desert would be like.
I'm like, "Yeah, I wouldn't give in to
the devil either. That's awesome. I
could do that." Um I But except I
started watching this show recently
called Alone. Has anyone watched this on
Netflix? I am obsessed. I'm obsessed. Um
it's there's a new season. I'm I'm not a
representative of Netflix, but hey, it's
really good. So, for those of you who
don't know, essentially the premise is
there's a group of people. They take
them out to the wilderness. They each
get their own little spot and it is who
can be out there the longest. And it
sounds simple um and it sounds cool but
it's it's really crazy. This this season
they're like just inside the Arctic
Circle. So it gets to like -40 degrees.
There's bears, there's wolves, and then
it gets even crazier because it because
it's the Arctic Circle and the time of
year, the longer they go, the darker it
stays. And so there's a point where the
sun stops rising and it stays cold and
all the animals go away and they're just
in the dark alone. It's really cool. Um
the re the reason I mean it the reason I
enjoy it is because I like to watch
these people. They're so confident. I
mean, they start they're like, "I would
rather die than tap out." And then like
a day later, they're in the fetal
position weeping, saying they miss their
mom. I'm I'm not exaggerating. They just
completely like they're pros. They
They're survivalists. They've been
trained and you get to watch them go out
there and just get utterly wrecked.
Like, it's it's so fun. It's really fun.
And what I love about it really, and I
might sound like a psychopath, I like to
watch them break.
I like seriously I I was watching with
my son and we're watching it and I'm
like I see some like tears building up.
I'm like oh here it comes. Here it
comes. They're about to lose it. They're
about to lose it. It's really sick. I'm
sorry. Um but I I bring this up because
really what's really interesting is, you
know, they go through a whole lot of
things. Like they they have to like boil
their water before they drink it.
They're only allowed like an axe, some
clothes, maybe a pot. And so they're
it's true like survival of the fittest
and they have medical issues like a guy
landed on his arrow like they have
frostbite but really what gets people is
the isolation like they when they're out
there alone with their own thoughts and
they just they can't handle it. And so
there's like five people right off the
bat that you just you lose them because
of that. And I like this show because it
helps me just barely scratch the surface
as to what Jesus might have felt and
gone through in the wilderness because
for him to be able to do this with the
devil and answer this way after 40 days
of wilderness and fasting is pretty
remarkable because these sweet people um
they they can barely do it. They I they
really can't. Um and so it's it it's
like I always think camping is really
cool. I always think all that, but I
romanticize it and it's so much harder.
So, so much harder than I think. Um,
because at some point it switches and
something clicks and you realize, wow, I
am so reliant on my comforts. I don't
even realize how reliant I am. And
that's why fasting from anything is so
effing hard. It's so hard because rarely
do we understand just how utterly
dependent we are on our comforts of the
modern world. So much of our lives are
devoted uh to being as comfortable as
possible. I I I don't just mean
physically although that of course is a
is a big part of what we're talking
about but also like mentally,
emotionally, spiritually. We are doing
whatever we can to avoid discomfort,
uncertainty, and suffering. Like that's
just how we're wired is to avoid those
things. I I read this really great book
um last year called Dopamine Nation. Um
and Anna LMK, she says this in in the
book. She says, "The reason we're all so
miserable may be because we're working
so hard to avoid being miserable."
I love this. It it and I know what this
might sound like. And no, I'm not going
to shame you for enjoying things or
wanting to avoid pain and suffering
because I I've I've heard that sermon
and that is not what I want to do today.
Um what I am getting at uh is that we
are rarely brought to the point when we
no longer can lean on those things that
make us feel better. Like usually if if
one thing is taken away from us, we have
another thing to replace it with pretty
quickly that helps us feel better and
get through the day, right? Like I I am
the king of making sure my comforts are
in place. This is why when I walk into
the doughnut shop in the morning, she
goes, "The usual."
Yep. Because that's the only way I can
get out of bed is that doughnut shop.
Some of you might be sitting there
thinking, you know, I don't need any
comfort. Like I I probably would have
been like that. It's like, I'm fine. I
could take all that stuff away. No
problem. I am not reliant on those
things. And my son would probably be
saying the same thing here. But the
truth is like us living in this cultural
moment and in this country, we are very
fortunate to have all the things that we
have, right? We have a lot of comforts
that we don't even really think about
most of the time.
And and and I I can I found this out
like if you really don't believe me, you
need to come to my elementary school
when the internet goes down. like you
watch a group of adults completely just
decay into insanity. That it is it is a
wonder to behold. Um or if you really
want to see that, you could go to a
restaurant with Lily and I and see what
happens when the waiter says they only
carry Pepsi products. Um
it it's it happens. Or or like me a few
a few weeks ago, I was waiting like
three weeks for a podcast episode to
come out. The date was there. It was
gonna come out and it didn't come out
that day. And you would have thought I
was losing my mind. I was like, "How
dare they not release the PODCAST
EPISODE ON THE day they said?" Like,
"Oh, it's gross. It's gross." And that's
just the small stuff. Like that that's
that's just the small stuff. What about
the deeper stuff? Like when we can no
longer distract our mind from drifting
to that one memory from childhood that
scarred us forever.
Or
or what if we can't escape the hard
conversation anymore? Or you can't numb
yourself enough to bypass the grief of
an unexpected death?
Because that that's what Lent gets at.
This is the heart of it. that Lent is a
reminder of our finitude, our fragility,
our mortality.
When we are brought to the end of
ourselves and realize that what we
thought could sustain us is just simply
not enough. It's just not enough.
But day after day after day, we are
wandering through our own wilderness,
doing everything in our power to
convince ourselves we're not there.
Whatever we can do to distract ourselves
from where we are, we will do it.
However, it is in the wilderness when we
become painfully aware of how delicate
we are, how fragile we are, what we are
and what we are not. But most
importantly, we come face to face with
the one who suffers with us.
The one who brings wisdom, grace, love,
and a deep, profound joy. Um, anyone who
knows me knows that I am a massive
Thomas Merin fan. Uh, definitely a
fanboy. Uh, Thomas Merin said said this
about Ash Wednesday, uh, specifically,
but it it applies so well to Lent as a
whole. He said this, "Lent is full of
joy.
The source of all sorrow is the illusion
that of ourselves we are anything but
dust.
The true sorrow comes when we try to
convince ourselves we are anything but
dust in the wind.
How many of you are singing the song in
your head right now? Good. That's what I
wanted to do.
We We are not enough. We are fragile,
delicate, weak human beings that
desperately need the sustaining power of
Christ. I that felt a little negative,
right? It was almost a little fire and
brimstone.
This isn't self-deprecation, though.
It's the somber reality that we're not
superheroes.
We just we aren't. As much as we like
the like hash no days off, like we can
just keep going, all that, like we
can't. There is a limit. And what I
believe to be one of our biggest
obstacles as Christians today is that we
so fiercely avoid discomfort,
uncertainty, and suffering. And most of
the time we are completely unaware that
we're doing it.
And once we can become aware of it and
learn how to best exist within the
wilderness, we can live a much more rich
and full life in Christ. So, I have the
I have this uh the title of this is uh
how the hell am I supposed to do this?
Well, uh this is where the spiritual
discipline of fasting comes in like this
is this is where what it's about because
most of us are thrown into a wilderness
without warning or choice.
Whether it's through divorce, disease,
unemployment, financial challenges,
fasting becomes even more important of a
practice because like any exercise, the
only way we learn how to weather the
wilderness is to work the muscles that
are required to do so.
We we have to work those muscles. But
what we we do the opposite. We just
distract, avoid, numb
that. So then every wilderness just
becomes us in this weird cycle of
numbing, avoiding, avoiding, avoiding.
And the church has practiced fasting for
a long time. But it started to shift and
morph into weird territory when I was a
kid. Like I I remember very well and I
witnessed fasting and prayer
specifically be used to manipulate
people so horribly and where people
would use it to say if we do this just
right God will give us this. It's like
oo building campaign better fast so God
gives us the money.
I I've I've watched it over and over and
over again. Um, Richard Foster, one of
my favorite Quaker writers, he says
this, um, to use good things to our own
ends is always a sign of false religion.
How easy it is to take something like
fasting and try to use it to get God to
do what we want. At times, there is such
a stress upon the blessings and benefits
of fasting that we would be tempted to
believe that with a little fast, we
could have the world, including God,
eating out of our hands.
Preach, Richard.
But I I mean I am I alone? Have you guys
witnessed that too? And so for me
because I watched all that happen, I
would just avoid spiritual disciplines.
Be like I can't I just watch people use
this for for their own good. It's false
religion.
So clearly it's not about what we fast
or the reason like what we're trying to
get from fasting. It's it's the state of
our hearts. And if it if it's not
starting there, we're in trouble.
Fasting must not be to get something
from God, but to strip us down, open us
up until our inner soil to receive what
God is giving or saying.
We don't like to be stripped down or or
or opened up.
And and I imagine that if soil had
feelings, they would it tilling probably
doesn't feel super good. Um, and
practically most people choose to fast
from food, which I I think most people
have done some sort of food fast. But I
will stress anytime I talk about
fasting, I really really want to make
sure I say this that depending on your
relationship to food, for instance, eat
if if eating disorders are a part of
your life, a food fast is probably not
wise. So, I just I like to say that
right off the bat that I'm not telling
you to start giving up food for like
three weeks. Like, no. No, that's not
what I'm saying. But but when it does
come to choosing something to fast from,
in my experience, it is best to choose
something that is truly challenging
and can be to the best of your ability
private.
Because what I notice a lot is suddenly
all the Facebook posts of see you in 40
days, giving up social media for Lent.
And I just go God. And if that's what
you're doing, cool.
I think it's great. I was just talking
to somebody last night who's doing that.
I think that's beautiful. But it's the
weird thing of like advertising that
you're doing it is strange. That's
strange to me. And and I think if if we
know our Bible, we know that that does
not go well. Um when we start
advertising um for for instance, I I
fasted a few years ago. I fasted from
any media or entertainment from lunch on
till the next morning. And so that
doesn't sound that hard like it on
paper, but for me
it was brutal because I like to watch
something while I eat. I like to listen
to a podcast or music while I clean. I
like to read a book or this before bed.
I all that went away. And at the
beginning it was super super hard and I
almost gave up. But I stuck with it. And
after a while, what I noticed was
it got still and quiet. And I noticed
God drawing my attention to things in
myself that I never would have been
aware of
because of all the ridiculous amounts of
entertainment I was just feeding myself
with. Just ra entertain, entertain,
entertain.
So, so this is this is what I want to
encourage you is choose something
simple, choose something challenging and
stay with it. And if more like when you
slip up, don't shame yourself.
Please don't shame yourself because even
if you slip up, that is like a bell of
mindfulness that you can't do it because
you can't, which then draws your
attention back to Christ.
I have I have found that uh the right
Brett has quoted her a lot. Um, but the
writings of PMA Chodran has been very
significant for me. And she says this
about certain practices like this. Only
to the extent that we expose ourselves
over and over to annihilation can that
which is indestructible be found in us.
And and for me where where that quote
really lands is what is truly
indestructible in us is the all
sustaining power of Christ.
It's Christ in us that is
undestructible.
We We cannot be destroyed because of who
is in us.
The neverending grace, the love of the
one who suffers with us, the one who was
brought to the end of himself
right to the brink in the wilderness.
And even while he was tested, he knew we
are sustained by every word that comes
from the mouth of God.
And so that that is why we fast every
year as a church to be reminded that
ultimately we are sustained by grace and
love and the love of God in the word
made flesh who is Christ. And so I don't
I I really was tempted to be like here's
how you should fast. Here's how long.
Here are some options of what you could
do. And I no I don't want to tell you
that. I don't want to do that. That's
between you and the Lord truly.
But I did want to make us very very
aware that when we walk out of this
building that we know that the reason
fasting exists is so we can be reminded
that we cannot sustain ourselves. Only
Christ can sustain us. Period. End of
story.
So the season of Lent
is a time to practice wilderness
so that we can fully live in the
ultimate truth that we are not destroyed
by death but made alive with Christ.
Because in Lent, we're not just like,
"Ah, this is hard." We're looking
forward
towards the holy days, right?
We're looking towards Good Friday,
towards Holy Saturday, towards Easter
morning.
That's the beauty of our Lent time is we
know we know who wins.
Our calling is to continually do
whatever we can to stay and not run from
the things that draw us closer to God.
A lot of times that's what we're doing.
We're running away and avoiding the
thing that will actually draw us closer
to God. That will clear out the space
for God to speak the thing you've been
waiting to hear.
So, we will end with this.
Henry Nen um is I I got all the quotes
tonight. I'm sorry, you guys. So many
quotes. Um Henry Nan wrote a really
beautiful journal um while he was
visiting uh the Abbey of Gethsemane. Um
it's it's called Genese Diary. I never
know if I'm saying it right, but I've
read this book maybe four or five times.
It's really beautiful. But this quote
from that while he was in silence, the
food was really weird. He was having to
do manual labor every day and he was
really struggling. He wrote this.
God's grace is indeed like a gentle
morning dew and a soft rain that gives
new life to barren soil.
My call is indeed to become more and
more sensitive to the morning dew and to
open my soul to the rain so that my
innermost self can bring forth a savior.
In the name of the Father and the Son
and the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So, as we prepare for communion, we need
to be reminded that on the night Jesus
was betrayed, he had one final meal with
his disciples. And at that meal, he
stood and held up a loaf of bread and
then broke it and said, "Take and eat.
This is my body broken for you." Then he
held up the cup of wine and he said,
"This is my blood shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread or drink this cup,
remember me. So that's what we are doing
tonight. As we come forward,
a couple of instructions. We always
start with the front row and we come and
we form a line in here. Um we practice
an open table. That means if you're here
tonight and you want to participate, you
are more than welcome to. There is
nothing that would hold you back from
that. Um also be super aware that the
red is wine and the white is grape
juice. Um, and once you have your
elements, you're free to partake
whenever and however you'd like. Um,
some people come and kneel at the front.
Um, some people take it back to their
seats. Some people, um, uh, partake
right away. It's totally up to you. We
will not lead you through that moment.
Um, okay.
This is the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord.
It is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come
you who have much faith and you who have
little. You who have been here often and
you who have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed. Come because it is the Lord who
invites you. And it is his will that
those who want him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
We're gonna close tonight close tonight
with a song called um It Is Well. And as
I was thinking through Jesse's message
and kind of um choosing like this
willingness to be uncomfortable, this
willingness to put oursel in a situation
where things are not the way that we
would normally curate them to be. Um
these words these words came to my mind
just this agreement this agreement kind
of to to allow God to be to be enough
for us doesn't feel like there doesn't
feel like there's enough to to be well
in inwardly when outwardly things are
not what we wished that they were
so if you guys would like to sing along
with us if you want this song you're
more than welcome or you're free to sit
back and just let this wash over you.
But I just wanted us to go into our week
kind of acknowledging this need that we
have. Um for things to be right,
sometimes that doesn't work out. And uh
hopefully in the midst of that
wilderness that Jesse was talking about,
we can um we can we can choose this
inner wellness knowing that God's love
is here and it is sustaining us.
Grander
is quick to be
by the sound of his voice.
The shen
can be cold and broken for
it all. Through it all through it all.
My eyes are on you.
>> Through it all. Through it all. It is
well.
>> Through it all. through it all. My eyes
are on you.
>> It is well
with me.
>> With me,
I believe.
Even
my eyes can see
that run
will be thrown into the midst of sea.
Through it all, through it all, it all
through it all. Through it all, my eyes
are on you.
Through it all, through it all is well.
>> Through it all, through it all. My eyes
are on you. It is well.
It is well.
My soul
rests
the waves of wind still knows
his name.
So let go of my soul
and trust in him. The waves are still
his name.
>> Yes. The ways are
You know
his name
is
well.
Sing that again.
>> Sing that again.
with
my soul.
He
is
with
my soul.
with my
soul.
He is
with
my soul.
his way.
My
soul
is
well
with my
soul.
is well
my
soul
is
He is
in our
my soul
through it Through
it all.
My eyes are on you.
>> Through it all.
Through it all. It is well.
>> Through it all. Through it all.
My eyes are on you.
>> Is well
with me.
Good job, guys.
Okay, thank you for being here tonight
and thank you worship team. That was
amazing.
All right, thank you so much for joining
us this evening. And if you are a
visitor, we would love for you to fill
out a card on your way out the door or
scan the infamous QR code and fill out
an online visitors card.
Uh we have meetups. So if you are
looking for some community support and
spiritual connection, uh it's a way at
the table that we um meet one another
and get to know one another on a deeper
level. So once again, our meetups are
available on the online QR code.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. And I want to
thank you if you are someone who gives
to the table. And I want to thank you if
you're someone who are considering
giving to the table. And I also want to
thank you if you pray for the financial
success of this congregation. And if
you're interested, scan the QR code.
All right. If you would like to, you may
stand up and open up your arms to
receive.
Open your hearts
and I will bless you with this
benediction.
You are a child of God.
You
This is true on your best day and it
true on your worst day.
And so as you go into the week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved,
that you are worthy,
and that you are accepted just as you
are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with.
Be blessed and we'll see you next
Sunday.
It is well
with my soul.